bueller held these giants to one run
over seven innings on saturday in his
second straight win he's coming off
seven shut up innings against arizona
last couple outings is dominant as we've
seen him 14 innings pitch only one
earned run a lot of swinging missing
there a lot of weak contact and he is
probably going to stick with the same
formula which is the hard stuff he will
mix in the slider and the curve ball
on the ground to second that's turner
shifted over there getting the out at
second that's all
the shrimps get more to the feuder's
choice
[Applause]
that's a bouncing ball to short lux will
feed muncie and a double play allows
walker mueller to face the minimum in
the first
they face off with anthony de slefani
for the second time in the last week
you've given up 12 runs all season going
into that game sunday he gave up 10
in two and two thirds
it'll be really interesting to see how
he tries to attack the dodgers the
daughters might need to be a little bit
more disciplined that he looks for the
chase because he tried to live in the
strike zone but the dodgers punished him
they torched him for those 10 runs
he pulls one off the end of the bat
under crawford's glove and scored him
into short left field
bets take second and a good start for
the dodgers taking advantage of the
defensive miss play
sun's setting lights are on
and there's a fly ball to center field
drifting back steven duggar is there and
that's that
so bets is stranded at second no runs no
hits an error in a man left no score
after one
crawford having one of his best seasons
one of the most productive hitters in
the national league this month crawford
toward the right field corner it is off
the base of the wall
[Applause]
and crawford that karen came right to
bets but it got to him so quickly i
guess he couldn't hold it
crawford easily makes it into second
giants with their first man in scoring
position and it brings up donovan solano
that one fooled will smith and now
crawford's at third base
2-0
that should be deep enough to get
crawford home easily taylor near the
warning track
he won't even make a throw
and crawford scores the first run of the
game and the pass ball is going to lead
to a run two off two down second and
here's matt baby making his fourth start
at first base tonight
he lifts one down the line to right
pretty deep into the corner yastrimsky
going back it keeps on going it is gone
a superman effort from the estrelski but
the ball kept on flying and found the
seats to tie the game
he struck him out one run one hit baby's
home run his second of the season evens
the score at one after two
three two duggar rips one into right
field base hit and steven duggar another
good at bat
worked the count full took some tough
pitches and then just scorched a liner
for a lead-off single
into the hands breaking the bat roller
to first baity to the bag two gone and
mike dempsey coming up as duggar goes to
third
the 01
come backer to beulah
easy play soft toss inning is over
no runs one hit one left after two and a
half giants and dodgers are tied at one
the dodgers a half game off of the best
record in baseball
they've only had cody ballinger for
about a week one-two pitch bueller
strikes out swinging chased the sliders
with diesel funny gets his second
strikeout all right so bases loaded for
gavin lox
tied up in the third here's the pitch
deluxe it is bounced to first nice high
hop for lamont wade who fields it right
near the bag he steps on first for the
put out and the inning is over one gone
alex dickerson bellinger's supposed to
be in the lineup tomorrow but 2-2
strike three dickerson
tried to check his swing and he was tied
up in knots he went around according to
third base umpire dan rozelle
two gone brandon crawford dump it off of
the wall his first time goes the other
way this time suitsugo retreating and
making the catch going away
walker mueller with another quick inning
one two three but the giants in the
fourth
good look at that infield in for the
giants runners at first and third and
nobody out
2-1 tsutsugo got jammed wade is coming
home and the tag
he is out at home plate
wow wasn't that easy
posey finally found him
over the second base goes baby
that's all for two tonight one for five
in this series
betty at third suzugo at second big
pitch here 3-2
bent strikes out swinging
that was big time from anthony de
slefani seven in a row retired by
bueller as jason vossler comes up
nice cutter
third k for mueller two out nobody on
and steven duggar coming up
he hits that one high and deep to right
field mookie betts going back it is gone
it's his third home run of the year
two to one giants
he is letting his bat head do the
talking and it is getting louder and
louder now chris taylor who walked his
last time up can disclose through
another mess a 1-2
line drive off the glove of crawford in
the left field for a base hit
taylor delivers a scorching
liner to left
turner comes in to score the dodgers and
giants are now tied at two and so spoils
the end of the game for anthony
two two two on both his responsibility
they take off three two is hit high in
the air to shallow left field dickerson
is there
for the catch so barrage after falling
behind
comes back to get his man and stranded
those two runners
first and second one gone in a tie game
2-2
bouncing ball to second muncie gets
there goes to second one laid at first
at the corners with two out
second and third two out lets it fly
driven to left center field tsutsugo
makes the
yoshi's saving the day
a step in front of the wall a bit of a
leap and a terrific catch yoshi sugo and
they're first and second with one god
buster posey coming up here's the pitch
posey hits a high fly ball left field
going back on the ball suzugo all the
way back it's gone
buster posey
a three run homer to break the tie five
to two giants here in the eighth inning
so it is tyler rogers making his major
league leading 27th appearance of the
year the tying run at the plate is
barnes is 1-0
barnes hits it to deep
the game is tied at five barnes with the
pension home run
his second home run of the year and now
pujols
pujo sets one deep
field
it is caught
caught by talkman
this emotional roller coaster
continues to the 10th
lamont wayne's been on base three times
tonight he's drawn two walks
right center field that's going to get
it done
noisy up with it duggar will score
easily
and the giants are back ahead six to
five
and the 1-1 to evan longoria
by ball right field and deep
way back noisy can't get it
it's off the wall and two runs will
score on the longoria double
it is now eight to five
dodgers that need some more magic down
three harlan garcia who's pitching
better and better for san francisco on
to try and finish it
there is talkman and the ball game is
over
the giants they had to win it two
different times